hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast novel applications
automated electrophysiology and ion
channel drug discovery I am Brenda Kelly
Kim elaborate and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
molecular devices molecular devices is
one of the world's leading providers of
high-performance bioanalytical
measurement solutions for life science
research pharmaceutical and biotech
cuticle development included within a
broad product portfolio our platforms
for high-throughput patch-clamp
electrophysiology and axon instruments
conventional electrophysiology products
these leading edge products and power
scientists to improve productivity and
effectiveness ultimately accelerating
research and the discovery of new
therapeutics before we start there are a
few instructions we want to hear from
you during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers are always welcome to
you can do this by hitting the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and typing in your
comments and questions we'll try to get
to as many as we can and we'll follow up
if we don't have time today if you want
a better look you can enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem to the green Q&A button lower
left I would now like to introduce
today's presenters dr. rocks urn and
David way dr. Watson is a principal
research scientist at eli lilly and
company where he supports drug discovery
projects with ion channel assays and
expertise prior to eli lilly rock was
red point x 0 where he focused on
discovery of novel TRP channel
modulators and
Purdue Pharma where he supported the
discovery of novel pain therapeutics at
Purdue his group was among the first to
introduce automated electrophysiology
which gave him an opportunity to create
software development patch Express
system dr. David way is a research
scientist leading the ion channel
services group at europen pan labs there
he serves as a principal investigator
for oversight of ion channel drug
discovery and safety assessment projects
including discovery and safety programs
for over 60 ion channel targets for more
than 300 clients in industry and
academia prior to joining eurofins David
work to other life science companies
including emd millipore and target set
where he designed and developed the
first novel hi drew plot in vitro slice
electrophysiology recording system in
support of drug discovery and toxicology
programs I will now turn it over to dr.
Sun and dr. way for their presentation
thanks for logging in and thanks to
molecular devices for giving me the
opportunity to talk about our experience
with ironworks Barracuda more
specifically about some of the
experimental approaches for
voltage-gated ion channels we developed
within the last few years in essence I
will argue that sub Giga seal automated
patch flatform onwards Barracuda is
suitable for testing compounds on
modulation of voltage-gated ion channels
held in controlled conformation and at
steady state there's approximately 300
genes encoding ion channels each gene
may have hundreds of snips and mutations
some of them are functionally irrelevant
and around 100 have been associated with
channel artists in addition ion channels
can heterodimer eyes and foreign
complexes with associated proteins which
can in turn service drug targets the
complexity of potential drug I entire
interaction is enormous historically
iron shall present a fruitful class of
drug targets this slide lists a few
commonly prescribed drugs targeting ion
channels it is noteworthy that most of
them are older drugs and nearly all were
discovered empirically our understanding
of ion channels in continuously
improving and opening the novel
possibilities for rational drug
discovery approaches for example genetic
mutation search for example a sip or a
ritual myalgia point2 nav 17 as a target
for pain therapy snail talks in the rice
peptides econo tight clinically
validates n-type calcium channel at the
target for pain the target based ion
channel drug discovery efforts were
however so far not very successful and
this is reflected in a few new approved
drugs targeting ion channels and lack of
return on investment and then shift of
research and discovery investment away
from my own channel research in some
cases hotel boutique areas with
substantial amount of ion channel
targets get deprioritized while the
indus
struggles it bring the new ion channel
drugs to market the scientific advances
in our understanding of ion channel
structure and function advanced rapidly
this is the large degree due to
technological breakthroughs such as the
ability to salt crystal structure for
ion channels the example on the Left
shows this is from genentech Burke shows
the binding of arrows sulfonamide to the
binding pocket on the voltage sensor in
the main for of chimeric now 17 to
correctly interpret structure-activity
relationship and guide compound
optimization functional data are needed
as well the selectivity profile for this
area of sulfonamide is shown on the
right the data were obtained with manual
patch recording where special care was
devoted to maintaining the sodium
channel isotype in equivalent
conformational state the complexity of
ion channel drug interaction in the need
for physiological relevance require
essays with substantial throughput and
good control of iron chair conformation
to show predictive value for the
downstream in vivo en pointe
electrophysiology with its ability to
control the manner and potential with
its direct readout and submitted samples
contemporary solution is often the most
suitable technique the low throughput of
manual patch is how are not adequate for
supportive industrial drug discovery and
automate that electro physiology was
introduced within the last 15 years to
address this need in a broad sense
automated electrophysiology instruments
can be divided into Giga CL instrument
capable of high fidelity voltage frame
and sub Giga CL instrument with
advantage of higher success rate this
stock will focus on ironworks Barracuda
which was introduced five years ago and
follow sign words HD and I were squadron
in the line of sub Giga sealed
instrument the main objective of
ironworks Barracuda was to retain the
functionality of ironworks quattro
primarily the high success rate and
stability of recording a schematic of
one of
see plate wealth is on the left and
briefly at the bottom of each well there
are 64 holes which get partially or
completely occupied by cell from Sal
addition then amphotericin or similar
perforating agents is perfused from the
bottom establish in electrical axis and
then electrical circuit composed of
common ground and individual recording
electrode clamps the memory of potential
and record the current recording that
nearly one hundred percent success rate
to become a routine in screaming in
electrophysiology became feasible the
limitation of Quattro is in a
discontinuous voltage clamp which is the
consequence of separately critic and
electronic at Vera cruda ends in
addition to meeting but the capability
of quattro to overcome these limitations
by integrating fluidics and
electrophysiological recordings as
illustrated in the center the silver one
is the electrode and the bluish is the
pipette and this integration enables
continuous clamping of membrane
potential and recording of current
during the compound addition complex
voltage clamp protocols and recording of
ligand gated channels became feasible on
ironworks Barracuda an additional
advantage of Amber's birthday is in its
payroll 384-well recording compared to
sequential 48 channel recording on
Quattro which gives it higher throughput
in our hands I'm worse Quattro was very
stable robust and axon for screen
purpose but due to the lack of
continuous voltage clamp and its
reliance on false based protocols
ironworks Quattro asus had some
limitation in supporting the
structure-activity relationship in
particular with accurate potency
determination of the inactivated state
of the channel and this was reflected in
disconnect between anchors Quattro and
patch Express generated IC 50 values for
a set of screen active compounds as
illustrated in this graph in our
experience that express
was a better predictor of potency in
manual patch and also efficacy in animal
models downstream so we result that the
expanded functionality of iron works
Barracuda may be suitable for the
continuous voltage clamp based protocols
such as the ones used on patch express
in manual patch in this way it would be
a better predictor of downstream assays
while retaining the high tribute of iron
bird squadra this is a look at the net
17 currents recorded on ironworks
Barracuda in population patch mode
depolarizing step evokes the current
which rapidly activates and inactivates
are shown in a the distribution of
currents was relatively narrow as shown
in be the average amplitude in our hands
was around 2.5 nano amp C and D show
activation of the current with a
threshold at minus 50 millivolts and
peak around minus 20 and E and F showing
activation with a have an activation
voltage of minus 50 millivolts overall
the properties of nav 17 current
recorded on ironworks Barracuda looked
comparable to the properties of net 17
currents recorded in manual patch to
accurately evaluate the effect of
compounds on defined conformational
state of the channel we needed to assure
that the biophysical properties of the
channel remains stable throughout the
experimental protocol for that reason we
monitor channel activation and
inactivation at the beginning and at the
end of 30 minute recordings in our
initial experiment we used signal flow
based internal solution and observed
large shift in channel activation in
activation during the experiment later
on we switched to potassium gluconate
based internal solution and added series
of wall steps and it dramatically
improved stability during individual run
and also during the six runs
of typical experimental day the bar
graph down at the bottom show at the
beginning at the end for both activation
and inactivation kinetics next we
designed the protocol capable of set of
assessing the effect of compounds on
channel in rested and partially
inactivated state using multiple
protocol mode of iron works for CUDA
holding potential was initially set to a
voltage where most channels were reside
in resting state with protocol 1 and
current amplitudes in response to 20
millisecond depolarizing steps are
plotted in be at the bottom next one of
the current will stabilize we stepped
the memory potential to a voltage
corresponding to approximately forty
percent inactivation this is the
protocol called t3 at the top and test
compounds were added during this step
finally we returned to the memory
potential to the resting membrane
potential and that is the protocol step
for Blanc the partially in activating
potential was measured during protocol
free and resting state blood was
determined by comparing currents evolved
during protocol 1 and protocol for two
additional quality control protocols
protocol 2 and five were added to
monitor net 17 activation inactivation
experiments performed in population
patch mode patch-clamp mode of iron
birdsburg could are associated with
substantial leak current conductance
uncompensated access resistance and a
non-uniform electrical field therefore
it was important to evaluate the
uniformity of inactivation from wealth
well and between experiments the example
in this slide illustrates the
distribution of inactivation across a
typical patch played the frequency
distribution of inactivation was narrow
a shown and histogram in a
and the spatial distribution of an
activation across the patch played was
uniform a shown the heat map in B we
were able to routinely obtain recordings
with an average fractional intubation of
approximately fifty percent and uniform
distribution of inactivation the key
strengths of our protocol was its
inability to evaluate compound effect
steady-state for two different channel
confirmations in this example one
micromolar tetracaine nearly completely
blocked net 17 currents the polarized
member potential and had almost no
effect on the channel at the
hyperpolarized membrane potential from
CRC's we can see that there was
approximately 100 full shift in potency
between resting and inactivated state a
similar evaluation was performed for
several different sodium channel
blockers and this table compares the
data from ironworks barracuda and data
generated by manual patch
electrophysiology in general there was a
good agreement between the two methods
for both compound potency and forced a
dependency the iron würzburg could I
just described both highly reproducible
as illustrated by test retest of 70
compounds IC 50 s were obtained at
partially in activating voltage and the
correlation coefficient was 0.96 we
further assess the 11 the key advantage
of the terminal block but the fixed
fractional activation is the ability to
directly compare potency of compounds
across multiple sodium channel subtypes
that may inactivate with different
kinetics and across different voltage
ranges a set of sodium channel
inhibitors was tested for block of six
sodium channel subtypes each sub ties
with Apollo
to a holding potential corresponding to
forty to fifty percent inactivation most
solemn channel inhibitors on this list
displays similar potency for all channel
subtypes suggesting that fractional
occupancy of rest in an inactivated
state was indeed similar across subtypes
an exceptionally sulfonamide which was
selected for t th sensitive sodium
channel subtypes were TTX resistant net
one's a 15 hour würzburg CUDA also
provided useful information about a
kinetics of compound association and
this is dissociation from the target
figure a and B Illustrated fast kinetics
of association and dissociation for
lidocaine and relatively slow kinetic
for sulfonamide summary data for a set
of eight compounds is in a table below
in conclusion it is likely the
development of sodium channel modulator
with superior therapeutic window will
require good selectivity strong state
dependence and an optimal kinetic
profile the eff is I just described can
support a drug discovery program by
providing information on all these three
attributes at a triplet required for
industrial drug discovery project so we
must examine the design of a similar
concocted protocol to measure block of
calcium current and encountered some
unexpected difficulties this slide
illustrates barium current conducted by
recombinant anti calcium channel and
recorded on an würzburg cuda in
population patch-clamp mode similar to
what is seen in manual electrophysiology
recordings the current activated rapidly
and inactivated slightly during the
polarizing pulse the current-voltage
relationship shows relativistic voltage
dependence of current activation most
likely resulting from imperfect voltage
control on ironworks Barracuda however
the stability over time was excellent
steady-state inactivation was examined
with a series of one second condition
impulses followed by a test post 20
millivolt are shown in b15 the boltzmann
equation to the task force amplitudes
indicated had an activation voltage of
approximately 20 million minus 20
millivolts similar to the voltage
dependence of activation steady-state
inactivation was stable in time the
protocol for assessment of compound
effect on channels in rest in an
inactivated state was similar to the con
cognitive protocol I just described for
sodium channels so I will not go in
detail similar to the sodium channel
protocol this protocol had the ability
to determine compound effect on channels
in resting and inactivated States within
the same recording example in B showed
that one micromolar trucks little effect
on current evoke from hyperpolarized
member and potential but almost
completely blocked currents from evoked
from the more depolarized membrane
potential in searcy curves we can see
that there was approximately hundred
fold shaped in potency although initial
experiments looked in at activation and
steady-state inactivation curves
indicated good stability of the
recording our time we wanted to assess
the stability of currents at partially
inactivates voltages in more detail to
this end we calculated the block
produced by additional buffer during the
depolarizing holding potential hit map
or the fractional current shows four
areas of patch plate where currents were
substantially reduced the areas of
reduced currents coincide with the
location of four ground electrode
situated underneath the patch plate and
the impact of such normal
on concentration-response curve for
trucks is illustrated in be considering
that silver silver chloride is a major
component of ground electrodes and also
based on previous reports of t-type
calcium channel blocked by filler ions
we hypothesized that the non-uniformity
seen in our recordings they be caused by
silver ions coming off the ground
electrode therefore we have a lead
effect of two silver salts on block of
n-type calcium current the blog by
silver chloride shown at the top in the
top row a and B and blocked by nitrate
at the bottom CND both South Block
n-type calcium currents with ic50 are
approximately point 5 micro molar and
the blog was not stay dependent we next
explore the potential for chelation of
silver by DMPs a heavy metal key later
approved for clinical use in cases of
heavy metal poisoning it was high it has
high affinity for silver and relatively
low affinity for calcium and magnesium
at high concentration the mps applied in
the extracellular solution blocked
n-type calcium currents with
approximately five millimolar ic50
however edition of one millimolar DMPs
to the buffer completely prevented block
of calcium currents by silver nitrate
without siegen sees without significant
effect on n-type calcium current himself
we next tested the effect of DMPs on the
stability of n-type calcium currents in
ironworks Barracuda concatenated
protocol addition of da ps2 our solution
reverse the loss of current or the
ground electrodes are shown in the bar
graph it was the most effective when the
mps was added to both internal and
external solution the mps prevented the
loss of current during the buffer
addition and resulted in uniform
distribution of current calcium currents
shown in the hip nap of the fractional
current
to examine potential effect of the mpf
on the pharmacology of n-type calcium
currents we titrated a set of well
characterized calcium channel blockers
in the presence of dmps IC 50 values
obtained on Amber's barracuda in the
presence of the NPS generally agreed
well with the published data suggesting
that dmps does not alter channel from
ecology in summary the voltage control
of iron Berg's were recruited seems to
be sufficient for evaluation of compound
action on control confirmation of ion
channels at steady state the limitations
of iron works Barracuda limited remained
in sub GigaOM seal lack of signal
conditioning limited liquid handling
capability and in some cases toxicity of
components of recording apparatus in a
broad sense the incremental advances in
automated electrophysiology continue to
expand our ability in to investigate ion
channel drug targets in great detail and
increased Rupert before I end I just
want to acknowledge that all these work
has been performed with support of eli
lilly and company marked it most of the
ironworks barracuda recording mic all of
the manual patch and period was the Kree
the key to wrap up this project we also
have the access to general expertise in
the ironworks Barracuda in particularly
yerusha from chapters they rock from
Hanson and several colleagues from
molecular devices jimco Stanton
Shinyoung in particular headphone on so
I appreciate your time and interest and
I'm passing the control over to David
thank you very much Ross that's very
nice data and print patient so in my
friend I want to show you a couple of
channel violation data on the next
generation of the automated patch-clamp
system I work system so the purpose of
this study was twofold one is to support
the CEPA has the high-throughput
screening efforts across different sites
on different platforms January
validation data the second fold is that
we want to test the feasibility of using
I folks HT system in screening of the
voltage periods on channel compounds
because we know that this platform is
very good as the ligand-gated ion
channel compound screening but we want
to test the feasibility of whether we
can use this for voltage gated ion
channels before I go into the details of
the data I want to spend a couple slides
to briefly introduce you what we do who
we are and what we do you're in
scientific is the global company is
actually a leading CRO serving mostly
three main street out there different
industries the fit test the bathroom
Pharmaceuticals has an environmental
test and we are leaving actually number
one service providers in most of the
fields in this three different
industries and now we're getting into
the diagnostic industry tube we are
established in 1987 as European
scientific and now as of the year of
2015 we have around 20 and 25 right left
in 39 countries we have roughly twenty
three thousand full-time employee and we
have over over 150,000 analytical
methods available for the customer the
surgery or the business units that
actual services of team was in is
actually European farmer discovery
sources and this business units was
created by the integration and
acquisition of three different legacy
companies in nineteen in 2012 that the
your things up higher to like see 10
laps
2013 the legacy syrup and combine them
into Europe in syrup a lapse in 2013
2014 and the year of 2014 I the
Europeans required of the live feed
merck millipore emd millipore discovery
in the Roman solution business units and
take part of it and then integrate that
into the business units that we're in
now which is called your transformer
discovery sources and here shows the
global footprint on the map of the the
Europeans armor discovery services we
have a site infant child Missouri which
is the engine of service team is located
and and we have a site at the site here
we also have the ankle health services
the immuno signaling services and as
well as the emek types of sources and we
have a sighting dundee scotland which is
a home for the kinase profiler services
and we have the site in 48 frames which
is Alexei serve site it's a home for a
lot of in vitro assays as well as some
celery a phase there too and we also
have a site in taipei taiwan which is
the legacy panel that's life they
specialize in a lot of people in vivo
pharmacology tabs as well as some people
a day as well like I said bikin
combination of all these different
legacy services units that make us a
full service provider that can cover
your needs from the very beginning of
your target identification evaluation
and curio compounds go it goes into the
clinical trials
and I want to give you a brief
introduction about sea pup before before
I go into the actual data so late 1990s
and early 2000s we have a lot of
compounds withdraw from the markets due
to the treasured risk and the scientists
in the pharmaceutical industry and
academia actually figured out this is
largely due to the herb blockage or her
condition in the cardiac tissue and the
harbor refers to humans are global
really ditching channel and then the
current is referred as I gr and channel
also refers a qubit 11.1 so we know that
the blockage of her can lead to add
cardiac action potential duration
prolongation and da BS and which can
lead to the QT prolongation they
eventually up always makes risk or to
Sarge so all these findings leads to the
implantation of the ith step s7 b & e 14
guidelines early in the two thousand and
this hurt centric strategy that we're
using this very effective and somewhat
successful because the evidences are
since the implication of this guidelines
from 2013 2013 o drugs actually knew
from the market due to that Rosario crew
is make risk but the problem here is we
have a Kurd inhibition compound
collection we have a QT prolongation
come complexion this all represents a
large collection of the compounds or the
other drug candidates but the actual
compounds that have the potential for
rhythmic or to sort risk only represents
a very small subsets of this compound
collections so this leads to the
strategy is not very specific and leads
to a lot of unnecessary earning compound
nutrition during our drug discovery in
drug development process so this leads
to the CEPA per game or the soup soup
initiative so now we're looking to
there's multiple cardiac I
channels we know that QT prolongation
doesn't equal to produce milk risk or
traceur risk per game division doesn't
equal to charisma or to sock risk the
good evidences or evidence or examples
that prozac or verapamil blocks hurt but
also in here there's a cap on to the
l-type currents as roughly the same
concentration and there are cardiac safe
and then there's other examples of these
compounds too so the basic idea is that
you have a fine balance of inhibition of
the train the inward currents and the
outward currents actually that cancels
out they help each other so our hurt
centric all her only focus has a very
negative impact on the developing
moments as I just told you it caused
unnecessary hurting compound attrition
and caused a lot of potential of losing
these drugs so that does we have this
new paradigm of cardiac 50 about
evaluation which we call sepa
comprehensive in vitro perjury or
recently acid which basically contains
three different approaches one is that
we test the effects of the test
compounds on multiple cardiac ion
channels and then we'd feed all this
data into a computerized in silico model
reconstruction to predict the risk of
prison air or to Sarge and then we
retest the compound in the stem
cell-derived cardinal sites model to
confirm this finding actually the
another aspect of this is then we
confirm the finding in the early
clinical trial data so what are the
candidates for the current slack like I
just told you for the current candidate
we want to looking looking to the
cardiac I channels that has a that can
balance out the our currency in Beijing
and a war crime and inhibition so we
have before we have her fendrich her
eccentric strategy it has the hurt
blockage and now we're discussing about
the possibility of a sodium fast current
and filling the current task than the
l-type kept 12 and also the candidates
also has key belong qgq 77.1 banks
channel and care to one a rectifier
channel but we are stealing discussion
about what was the final list of the
channels that we're going to test
included into this cardiac current
candidates for it this particular study
I'm gonna just show you a validation
data on three different channels the
sodium 15 both the pickerington Blake
currents the her channel and as well as
the cap 12 channel on become ports but I
want to not mention that actually here
at the orphans i channel surf team we
offer a monthly service that we have
eight different cardiac fine channels on
the agricultural mnu patch-clamp to to
evaluate the multi-channel effects
calmly cardiac and channeled ion
channels and we are currently also
validating base currents or channels on
multiple on channel platforms which
include to the iOS platform i'm going to
show you any just a little bit here I
want to show you a brief a little video
introduce you the platform so I flux HT
platform was a play based micro fluidic
design that the play was defined or
divided into 32 different recording
patterns in each recording patterns you
can see that we have a compound welds to
compound loads for internal solution and
one wells for us cell and then the plate
was inserted into the platform and
everything was controlled by the
pressure there's no moving parts the
compound of the sale addition or the
fill flow the introduction introduction
of the internal solutions and
introduction of your test compounds or
controlled by the pressure to ensure the
fast introduction and removal of all the
components particularly test compounds
so the cells are flowing by the driven
by the pressure and then we apply a
nectar pressure on the trap which are
the top two panels that you can see on
this video and then to attract the cells
into the traps and then after that after
the feel was all change
you can see that if we can apply another
bigger pressure to to obtain the hotel
recording and then you start perfusing
gabba on the different reporting traps
and you can see that the traces show you
a dose-dependent response off the gaba
I've noticed that on the on your
computer screen there it might be a
little bit slack on the on the venue
which actually later on you're going to
have the PDF version of the slide back
and we can also watch this video on the
YouTube so like I just told you the high
flex HT system is a microfluidic play
based design so give you a lot of
flexibility in the assay development and
design and as well as a very fast super
fast actually compound regroup
introduction removal we're saying 100
milliseconds also temperature control
and as well as the individual soul
trapped recordings that you can test
multiple targets on the same page first
we validated the hacker channel on the
ice box HD in this set of experiment we
look into different aspects of the
experiments versus the current stability
we have the time edge vehicle control
throughout the course time course of the
reporting to make sure that the current
rundown is minimal because as you know
the current rundown might be a problem
for your phone's evaluation because the
reduction of your signal even without
introduction of the compound is a
problem you can't do a rundown
correction and whether it's linear looks
palatial but sometimes we know that just
by adding a compounded cost a
unpredicted drop of the currents so we
want to make sure that our current
reporting very stable across that the
time period we're applying to compound
and then we have a couple of reference
compound pharmacology on the cells to
make sure that they're agree with a
historical data in house and the
published literature data and then we
test the interim variability on
different days on the same reference
compound to make sure that our essays
robust enough and all this data was
generated on the orphans position at
Kurt cell lines and we also david cross
platform correlation compare the data
collected from I flux to the Q patch on
this slide you can see leaves a pretty
standard hurt all these protocol
and the upper panel you see the current
stability the current relative recording
time period is pretty stable I show you
three representative lines and on the
bottom panel to see to see the price the
baseline recording is very stable and
then after that you have a very nice
staff right skype step like those
dependent responsibilities of pride by
adding higher and higher concentration
mcs of pride and towards the end you
have a nice washout because the the
solution is the continuous perfusion
that solution exchange rates on this
platform it's really fast and then we
have a couple of reference compounds on
the hard channel we have FM enroll
people cry be 40 30 12 phenelzine and as
well as a time h vehicle control and you
can see that all the reference compounds
the closing data actually it's reading
close to report at many patch com data
and the vehicle control shows me and
more on that across via the time of
period of the reporting in the next set
of experiment we look into the intraday
precision to test the robustness of the
update we pick three compounds see the
prize s cannibal family being as well as
a metrical control and test those on two
different days you can see Dave 4 in D 1
and D 2 by a 50 value is really close to
each other show that our essay on the
unplugs the herg assay on netflix is
very detail robust then we compare the
punku value of the Russians compounds
between Q patch and artworks you can see
that they don't agree with each other
and the time entry vehicle control it's
very beautiful mineral running on
current right now next couple slides I'm
going to show you some sodium 15 data on
the iphone again we look into the
current stability with time metra
miracle control we look into some
reference pharmacology of the reference
compounds and we also look into the lake
current oncology induced by the AP x2
and barf I or another thing and again
all the data was generated with
reference precision that our cell line
network drives in the heck background in
this size you can see I show you use a
to post protocol to test the state
dependency of the test compounds in
rocks plantation here creepy already
explained that the state n NC of the
blockage so I'm not going to go into the
details of that but you can see our DN
or vehicle control shows a very stable
response across the time of the
recording and then you have a very nice
step response of lidocaine as you apply
higher concentration of lidocaine and
then until fully blockage of top
concentration and after that you have a
full reversal or washouts of the
lidocaine blockage effects and bring the
current back down to the baseline level
and you can see that the lidocaine shows
the post one IC 50 of 737 49 close to 1
million lower and the second post chills
IC 50 of 82.7 shows a very
state-dependent inhibition of lidocaine
which also gained this data risk with
literature values then we do the same
thing across all the humans as receptors
we have in-house we have map 11 through
18 but here the only difference is that
we actually use a usage dependent
protocol uses a point across protocol to
test the usage or frequency dependency
architects compounds are we use either
tetracaine by the king or a become a
thorn in my age so map 11 you see
there's a usage dependency between post
1 and post to a post 24 the potency data
and similar findings on the map 12 and
on the lower panel you can see vehicle
control time match vehicle control of
each receptor or channel and show you
minimal turnaround on throughout the
reporting there's no data for 13 and 14
again the potency value agree with
published literature value as well and
solar and cows data 15 and 16 and 17 and
18 on that 180 I want to
draw your attention to this album how
pounds it's known to it's very difficult
to get the potency value down to learn
animal arranged on the automatic
patch-clamp platforms for this epic on
palace ominous at 18 but in here I show
you that actually due to the fat
solution exchange and continues
profusion feature of the I floats we can
treat get the point Z value down to the
low nanomolar range and here you see the
vehicle control data that the baseline
response is very stable across the time
the next couple slides i want to show
you map 15 lake currents recording first
what we do is again on the top panel
this is the baseline response and then
we add different concentrations of a key
x 2 and you can see there's a nice dose
dependent response and then on the lower
left panel you see that the vehicle
controlled with little to no play
currents and then on the right panel you
see there should those dependent
response ATX to induce delayed currents
and we compare the I folks phone see
value to the king patch and they are
very close to each other and as well as
we agree with the historical values and
public published later literature values
and we also use the temperature control
feature of the a thought system test the
ATX two compounds at 37 degree and room
temperature and we didn't see their
suppose he shipped to be trained this
two different temperature
we have another cell line with beta 1 of
valerian 'it's and we want to tap that
so again we do say make similar
experiments and use a TX to do those the
response those response and you can see
that the baseline response again it's
very stable and then if you introduce
the different concentration of ATX to it
shows a very nice step like those
dependent response and again here's the
vehicle here's the dose-dependent
induced sleep parents by the ATX to
similar comparison we do 37 degree
online flux room temperature and compare
that with the Q patch there's a shift
between capatch policy values and I
books but we don't see a
temperature-dependent shift on potency
of a px 2 on the map water available on
cell line and next I want to show you
that we can block this a case to induced
a laker inspiron olive thing which is a
known the carb blocker again you see
here's the baseline response and then we
use BK x 2 to induce the lake currents
and we use different concentrations of
remodeling to block it you can see
there's some nice those dependent
blockage of the lake currents with
washouts reversal and we compared those
bones leave at acuity and betraying the
ibooks and q patch and the phone
together is really close from different
platforms in the next set of experiment
i want to show you some preliminary
preliminary data we have on the cap 12
so on the cap one to tell one was known
the technical challenger or difficult on
the hypothesis automated patch crime
platforms mostly due to the current
stability or ground round down here I
want to show you with ibooks now we can
get very stable baseline response of the
time and vehicle control historically
was a way we're dealing with the car
around Alex cap one who is actually
unnatural reuse
perforated patch and Quattro is probably
shows the the best or with minimal car
around on compared to other true
wholesale current recordings such as
Patrick's per sq patch will are the
wholesale ultimatum patch-clamp
subsystems actually right now when
people are dealing with Ron down
problems of cap 12 even on the q petrol
patch express or other wholesale has
class systems so we actually also tried
preferred apache instead of wholesale
reporting but here i want to show you
some very exciting preliminary data
actually singapore recording modes which
is the upper panel and population lives
which is lower panel and the
superimposed calcium currents over a
different time that they are pretty
stable throughout the reporting copy
area which is about 10 to 15 minutes
with unit minimal car around a
specialist reporting was achieved by
hotel reporting this is very exciting
and I will continue to test on
pharmacology of the referenced pathology
of cat want you on this slide I want to
show you the capabilities of the
n-channel service team here at your
friends perhaps we have a couple of men
you catch a break we have Q patch system
here we have several language across
whole system as well as the I flicks HT
system I just showed you we also have a
high content image expressed system as
well as an exhale Mastro system which we
currently use for cotton monocytes
immediate recording we also have a
couple plate readers for fluorescent
signal readings and as well as a lots of
liquor handlers for lab level
information with that I want to thank
you for your time and audience and thank
you very much if you have questions you
can ask now thank you
excellent presentation big thank yous to
dr. wayne dr. stern for bringing that
information to us before we get started
with all your questions here's a quick
reminder about how to reach us today
questions can be sent via the green Q&A
button the lower left of the
presentation window will get to as many
as we can today in addition I want to
remind our audience that you'll be
seeing some polling questions appearing
on your screen in just a moment if you
could take a little time to answer them
so that we may make sure we're bringing
you the most relevant information
possible we'd be very appreciative of
that now we will get right to our first
question of course first question is for
David what role do you see the ion flux
instrument filling in the CEPA
investigation beyond h ERG that's a good
question actually that's the reason why
we want to test and validate all this
different cardiac I'd channels on it
omnia high flux so based on the plates
and my crew fully designed but like i
said in the presentation people thought
this platform is ideal for the
ligand-gated ion channel so this is this
set of studies actually particular to
evaluate the feasibility of using this
platform to test voltage-gated ion
channels and now we see that actually it
is feasible as people to test all
different cardiac on channel
voltage-gated ion channels on this
system so definitely we can use this for
superfast other than other platforms
that we can use for c-pod on channel
targets as well great we do have another
question also for David why do you
normalize the peak current um the pit
current so it's it's it's a time
accumulate accumulate accumulate
addition of the compound so we have to
normalize that to the baseline this is
continuous perfusion and mimicking that
what we do on a menu patch-clamp and the
other part of this is for the cap 12 as
you know our car around
is the big problem so we want to make
sure throughout that the time course of
the recording or adult reduction of the
current amplitude without without the
compound addition is minimal because
otherwise you might have unexpected and
unpredictable potency shift of your test
compound I see okay another question
David what can cause the current to be
non-standard between concentrations if
the concentrations are added
sequentially and on the same cells um
that's a good question actually that's a
different system design compared to
compare I flux to maybe I oral or maybe
our spirit ruda is that of the Quattro
and Barracuda it's a platter based
system and I looks I'm folks HT system
is actually a microfluidic basis system
so actually everything is dynamic once
you trap the cells on the side of the
wall instead of on the planner on the
floor you have continuous perfusion and
compound addition all the time so if you
introduce a compound new compound
concentration with high pressure
actually you might have a risk of losing
sales on the traps because I just showed
you on I click system you have two traps
each recording patent and each trap can
require up to 20 cells but those 20 20
trysail traps are may be fully or
partially occupied by the cell and if
you use a high pressure to induce a new
test compound solution you might have a
danger to lose the cell which which
leads to a decrease in the co quality or
seal resistance and leads to the the
change in the current response I see
okay we have another question what is
the volume range of the micro fluidics
transfer to the cell well for each
instrument or compound and wash out as
well um depends on your pressure setting
tip with typical pressure settings on
this platform you can add fifty
microliters of test compound into each
will which if you use that for
continuous perfusion actually can last
you up
two hours which is another benefit of
this platform it really reduced the
other consumables they use use of the
test compounds as well as the buffer I
see our kind our next question is for a
rock now that you've optimized the essay
for nav 1.7 and have 2.2 are you
screening can you approximate your
throughput we developed those assets in
parallel with screen and then use them
as a follow-up only but in general I
onwards Barracuda is capable of
screaming and we looked into a few
possibilities but then ended up doing
only small scale screens with less than
10,000 compounds and this is mostly due
to the cost for data point and the fact
that in our pilot screens in those
particular targets we did not see
substantial advantage of area where life
expands your essays such a slipper the
true put that depends largely on the
type of a say for example for some of
the ligand-gated channels we were able
to run up to 15 plates a day and those
protocols were using relatively moderate
voltage clamp at minus eighty millivolts
and they were relatively short around
ten minutes but for the concatenated
protocols that I showed earlier the
troop hood was a bit lower so on typical
experimental day we would run about six
plate okay our next question also for
you rock how do you see Iron Works
Barracuda fitting into the FDA's new
super initiative is there anything
unique about the instrument capabilities
that would help to my understanding see
by still evolving and amber couldcould I
said it could profile all of the ion
channels that are currently considered
as part of civ initiative I could not
comment on the predictive value of berk
udah versus other automated
electrophysiology instruments
and I also don't know what the
acceptance of Barracuda by the
regulators would be but based on our
experience I would be surprised if there
are any large differences between
barracuda and other such as Giga CL
instruments small differences are
expected considering that each
instrument cares some limitations for
example Barracuda may have hard time
accommodating simulation of cardiac
action potential protocol but could I
may have a little bit lower seal and not
as accurate voltage clamp but on the
other hand where it could have
substantial advantage in higher success
rate at higher throughput it is very
versatile and one great thing that we
observe this preservation of
intercellular milia because it uses
amateurs in perforated patch I see ok
another question for you rock how early
in your drug development process are you
performing H ERG and seba assays um we
we're relatively slow so we assess
compound properties in silico initially
and in general prior to selecting the
lid molecules we would conduct only a
limited amount of her testing which
typically involves both binding and
functional assays and this may differ if
we see a herd liability we may go a
little bit more intense the profiling of
compounds on other ion channels in
potential super panel berries and in
general we would conduct mostly testing
on net 15 and l-type calcium channel now
as far as the automated patch in general
overall the advance of automated
electrophysiology drastically increase
the throughput of F electrophysiology
based assays and in general the quality
of the data obtained on automated
electrophysiology is accepted even for
final compounds potency determination
in a search automated electrophysiology
delivered on its objectives a bit of
problem is the cost of profiling and
then they're specifically abilities of
each chemical series and that together
necessitates more limited and more
customized approaches and for that
reason I don't anticipate a massive
screening of compounds in panel of cpf
is early in the project where I do see
more role of high-throughput screen in
electrophysiology is for those targets
were such approach gives you an
advantage for example state-dependent
blockers of voltage-gated sodium
channels I see okay it's looking like we
have time for one more question our last
question why the delays in the maximum
of effect oh I don't know baby it is
that for you or me ah question did not
specify no yeah I don't know if it is
for me and looking at the concatenated
protocols there is a kinetic approach to
looking at the compound effect and a lot
of these compounds particularly the
sulfonamide the hill very slow kinetic
of binding so there would be but I did
not understand really the question its
fullest I don't know what was meant to
be delaying maximum effect okay I just
like to ask dr. way and dr. CERN if they
have any final comments for our audience
so we are done with our questions now no
I don't I don't have a specific question
for the audience but I would really
comment that automated electrophysiology
got a really long way and I can still
see progress so it's really exciting
time to be part of it yeah
I agree I think the new evolution or
involving of the new next generation of
these these platforms that like we show
today and some others on the markets
shows increase the field ecology
increase throughputs decreasing the cost
per data points so we have yet to see a
larger role that this platforms are
going to play in the discovery workflow
thank you again both for bringing this
important information to us if we didn't
get to your question today we will
definitely follow up with you with more
information we also want to thank
molecular devices for sponsoring today's
event today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through November
of 2016 you'll be receiving an email
from lab roots alerting you when it's
available for on-demand and posted on my
boots calm you're welcome to forward
this announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in with us live
today thank you for logging on
participating in today's interactive
broadcast we hope to see you again next
time goodbye